bonsoir à tous votre soirée spéciale
élection départementale continue en
Bourgogne il est 19h les derniers
bureaux de vote viennent de fermer en
Côte-d'Or ailleurs le dépouillement est
en cours premier résultat à communiquer
à 20h nous voulons tout à l'heure avec
Elsa Bezin et vous les retrouverez bien
évidemment sur notre site internet
france 3.fr Des chiffres et des lettres
aussi lionelet et Eric Sicot sont avec
nous pour analyser les nouveaux rapports
de force dans chaque département et puis
nous serons en direct de nos préfectures
avec Damien Boutillet à Mâcon Nathalie
bayfer à Auxerre Régis Guillon à Nevers
et à Dijon lise rigée seul chiffre que
nous pouvons vous donner avant 20h c'est
donc celui de la participation et il
était à 17h en Bourgogne de
46,1% contre à peine 42% niveau national
un chiffre stable à par rapport à la
semaine dernière et avant de détailler
par un département revenons sur un
dimanche d'élection avec l'ambiance en
Côte-d'Or dans le canton de
Saint-Apollinaire qui englobe aussi Ark
sur T de communes de communes où les
électeurs avaient le choix entre deux
binômes de droite et du Front national
les candidats aussi ont fait le tour des
bureaux de vote comme on constater
Sylvain Bouillot et Christophe gaillard
jour de vote pluvieux et candidats
soucieux depuis ce matin ce binôme du
canton de Saint-Apollinaire fait la
tournée des bureaux de vote arceau
fontaine françaises Arc-sur-Tille ici
les prétendants conseillent
départemental sanctuaire de la
participation mais pas seulement
dernier coup de tampon sur les cartes à
18h pour l'ensemble du canton à
l'exception de la commune de
Saint-Apollinaire dans les bureaux ont
fermé il y a quelques minutes à 19
heures
et malgré un temps à aller voter les
taux du participation donc du mal à
progresser difficile de trouver les
raisons de cette désertion dans les
bureaux de vote de Dijon et Chenôve où
se sont rendus Isabelle rivière et
Tiphaine Pfeiffer
car ce matin au bureau de vote de
Chenôve il n'y avait pas foule à 10
heures le taux de participation était en
baisse de 3% par rapport à la semaine
dernière à la même heure on dénombrait
586 votants pour plus de 8000 inscrits
une explication toute trouvée
je pense que le changement d'horaire y
est pour beaucoup c'est à dire que la
semaine dernière nous avions observé une
forte participation de 8h à 9h et là on
voit qu'il y a un décalage tout
simplement d'une heure les voilà les les
électeurs se sont levés une heure plus
tard au fil de la journée l'argument de
leur d'été ne tient plus on pourrait
donc penser que les bureaux de vote vont
se remplir mais pas du tout la preuve à
l'école maternelle château de Pouilly où
se trouve les bureaux de vote de Dijon 3
on a un peu plus électeurs qui n'ont pas
voté au premier tour on le constate sur
les cartes lorsqu'on tamponne après le
vote donc les personnes on a à peu près
on va dire une trentaine de personnes
qui sont venues en plus qui n'ont pas
voté au premier tour qui n'étaient pas
présent au deuxième tour il y a pas
beaucoup d'évolution plus actuellement à
voter
en principe les jeunes c'est entre 17 et
si certains ne comptent pas venir voter
d'autres au contraire ont une idée bien
précise de ce que représente un vote
c'est important c'est notre devoir en
fait on doit voter sinon on n'a rien à
dire en fait je pense voilà c'est tout
j'ai lu les programmes pour savoir de
quoi ça parlait et du coup voilà je sais
pour quoi j'ai voté et pas au hasard il
faut maintenant attendre 20 heures pour
connaître les premiers résultats le
prochain retour aux urnes se fera en
décembre pour les élections régionales
46,1 donc la participation à 17h en
Bourgogne ericsico comment expliquer ces
chiffres de la mobilisation écoutez il
est encore très difficile de donner une
signification générale à cette
abstention il faudra observer la
participation dans chaque canton pour
lui donner un véritable sens une seule
certitude une partie des électeurs était
privé de leur candidat du premier tour
et éliminé sans risque qu'on peut penser
que certains d'entre eux sont restés au
chaud à la maison et un sondage cette
semaine le laisser d'ailleurs clairement
entendre dans le cas de l'élimination
totale de leur camp la moitié des
électeurs de l'UMP et du FN et 40% des
électeurs de gauche dizaines de pas
vouloir aller voter mais avec la
nouvelle situation issue du premier tour
d'autres électeurs se sont aussi
mobilisés ont-ils entendu les appels des
uns et des autres les chiffres plutôt
stables de la participation le laisse
penser Lilian mollet on a beaucoup dit
que cette élection était inédite avec ce
système de binôme la situation au
deuxième tour elle aussi elle est
nouvelle oui pour faire simple on a un
vrai tripartisme droite-gauche Front
National qui s'est imposée dans le
paysage politique français dimanche
dernier à l'intérieur
bien installé derrière son bureau du
premier étage de son domicile
andréacharie épluche la presse du
week-end c'est donc dans l'intimité
familiale qu'il vit cette journée de
deuxième tour la sérénité semble
l'emporter sur le stress c'est pas la
guerre civile c'est qu'une élection donc
je suis plutôt très serein aujourd'hui
pour prudent certes
optimiste mais raisonnablement optimiste
donc voilà dans l'attente paisiblement
d'un résultat après avoir rencontré des
habitants de Paray-le-Monial le matin en
milieu d'après-midi direction le centre
culturel un bureau de vote que le leader
de l'opposition au conseil général est
candidat à sa succession trouve bien
vide on est toujours inquiet de la
participation
vraisemblablement à l'instant des deux
points au dessus de 2011 mais deux
points en dessous de la semaine dernière
voilà donc je pense que malgré tout les
gens vont se mobiliser il faut pas
oublier qu'on est sur la semaine du
décalage horaire donc je pense que
voilà passage à l'heure d'été donc je
pense que les gens vont se mobiliser
globalement au-dessus de 2011 et quand
vous avez glissé le bulletin dans l'urne
vous avez pensé à quoi au troisième tour
où c'est trop tôt non j'ai pensé à bien
vérifier que ça soit bien mon bulletin
trop tôt donc pour le 3e tour c'est pas
le sujet du jour en cas de victoire de
la droite tout à l'heure le sujet sera
forcément à l'ordre du jour le grand
favori à la présidence si le département
bascule c'est bien lui c'est ici à
Paray-le-Monial kandrea carry a prévu
d'attendre la proclamation des résultats
entouré de sa famille et de ses amis
la Saône-et-Loire objet de toutes les
attentions directes de la préfecture de
Mâcon Damien Bouttier Damien quelle est
la participation dans votre département
ce soir
bonsoir nos bonsoir à tous et bien la
participation à 17h était de
44,43%, c'est
0,05.2 - que dimanche dernier et puis si
on compare à 2011 c'est tout de même
plus 6,98 % nous l'avons un peu évoqué
c'est donc le département la plus grande
d'incertitude de existe
et oui basculera basculera pas c'est la
grande question sur 29 cantons 26 sont
encore en liste trois binômes sont
passés au premier tour de à droite
Chauffailles et charol et puis un gauche
pour Cluny et puis aujourd'hui il y
avait également 8 triangulaires et dans
six cas le Parti socialiste arrive en
tête alors on l'a vu il y a quelques
minutes un reportage sur André carry le
leader l'opposition on s'intéressera
bien évidemment à louer au Rémy Chatron
le président socialiste sortant tente de
sauver son poste à ce NUMP qui le
distançait de 1400 voix dimanche dernier
c'est donc à suivre et puis originalité
nous suivrons Saint-Vallier un duel PS
Front de Gauche ou le socialiste
Jean-Claude Lagrange a maintenu la
candidature de son binôme contre la
décision de son parti qui lui appelait
voter Frank gauche voilà quelques
quelques éléments plus élément plus
d'informations et surtout plus de
résultats toute la soirée depuis la
préfecture de Mâcon à tout à l'heure
Damien et c'est quoi c'est donc le
département bourguignon qui pourrait
suivre la tendance nationale avec un
retour de la droite aux affaires et oui
elle avait des élections la gauche était
très nettement majoritaire avec ce 39
élus entre 18 pour la droite aujourd'hui
le scénario le plus envisageable reste
une bascule en faveur de la droite mais
dans les deux camps on sait que ça va se
jouer à quelques cantons
particulièrement serré c'est le cas par
exemple dans les trois cantons ou les
trois candidats sont les mêmes qu'au
premier tour cuisent au Gergy ou le PS
n'a que quelques dizaines de voies
d'avance et pire de Brest sous la droite
était en tête avec une courte avance là
aussi un éventuel sursaut de la
mobilisation pour un tel lointelle peut
encore modifier les rapports de sort de
force pardon d'autres quand on restait
aussi très incertains comme Channing
Monceau ou Chalon 1 et Chalon 3 et sur
Chalon 1 où la droite est éliminée on
pourra observer le degré de porosité de
son électorale avec le FN d'autant que
le maire UMP Gilles plâtré a refusé de
se prononcer bref beaucoup de suspens
encore en Saône-et-Loire même si sur le
papier donc la donne reste plutôt
favorable à la droite prenons la
direction de l'Yonne Nathalie va faire
est à la préfecture d'océan Nathalie les
iconiens ont-ils la plus voté ce
dimanche
la participation à 17h s'établit à
50,61% contre
52,02 dimanche dernier c'est donc un
point 4 de moins mais comme lors du
premier tour les électeurs de l'Yonne
sont les meilleurs élèves de la région
et ce dès ce matin puisque à midi la
participation était déjà supérieur au
moyen régional et nationale l'état des
lieux rappelez-vous les enjeux dans ce
département
alors dans le nom a voté ce dimanche
dans 20 cantons à sur 21 un seul binôme
UMP a été élu dimanche dernier à l'issue
du premier tour il avait donc 17 duels
essentiellement droites face au FN et
trois triangulaires à Vallon Auxerre 3
et au serre 4 alors dans l'Yonne on sera
particulièrement attentif au score du
Front national qui a réalisé dimanche
dernier une percée tout à fait inédite
il était même arrivé en tête dans le
département avec dans certains cantons
des scores qui ont parfois dépassé les
40% et pour ce second tour le parti
frontiste est en lice dans tous les
cantons sauf un l'entrée de l'extrême
droite au sein de l'assemblée
départementale n'est donc pas exclure
notamment dans le nord de l'Yonne cela
dit malgré la progression du Front
national la droite traditionnelle est en
position très favorable pour asseoir sa
majorité et au passage conserver le
perchoir qui lui est acquis depuis 70
ans reste que cette bataille pour la
présidence s'annonce d'ores et déjà très
disputés à droite le clivage entre l'UMP
et l'UDI est apparu très nettement cette
semaine notamment au sujet du Front
républicain le troisième tour promet
donc une belle emploignade et des
tractations intenses qui ne manqueront
pas de débuter dès ce soir à l'annonce
des résultats merci Nathalie Eric une
chose est certaine la droite ne va donc
conserver ce département oui Nathalie le
disait elle a toujours eu une majorité
écrasante dans l'assemblée sortante elle
comptait 27 conseillers contre 15 pour
la gauche il a fort à parier que la
gauche va être encore affaiblie ce soir
elle a déjà perdu 10 points au premier
tour par rapport à 2011 ce soir elle
peut espérer gagner entre 3 et si
cantons donc a priori 12 élus au maximum
mais ce n'est pas pour autant que la
droite elle va sortir renforcée en effet
dans la région c'est bien dans l'Yonne
que le Front national fonde ses plus
grands espoirs il peut envisager entre 0
et 10 élus ces chances les plus
sérieuses étant à Torigny Pont sur Yonne
Saint-Florentin sans oublier Joigny et
Villeneuve où il affronte la gauche en
duel André Villiers a vu le danger cette
semaine le président
udi n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite il a
provoqué une réunion inédite avec des
candidats de droite et de gauche il
s'est ainsi imposé comme le leader de la
droite départementale d'une droite
morale et intransigeante face au FN si
le Front national n'a pas dédié ce soir
il en sortira sans doute renforcé en vue
de la bataille de jeudi prochain un gros
plan sur la Nièvre Régis Guillon est en
direct de la préfecture de Nevers Régis
d'abord la participation dans la Nièvre
et bien écoutez ici à 17h le taux de
participation s'est levait à 43,30% et
c'est un point et demi de mieux que par
rapport à dimanche mais en d'autres
termes quasiment 57% des électeurs
nivernés ne se sont pas déplacés nous
les enjeux de ce deuxième tour
oh bien d’abord je vous rappelle que ici
aucun des candidats n'a été élu dimanche
dernier ont voté donc à nouveau
aujourd'hui bien sûr dans les 17 cantons
que compte désormais le département de
la Nièvre les qualifier du premier tour
s'affrontant à travers 12 duels et 5
triangulaires alors ce soir un empathie
la majorité des départementales la
majorité départementale nivernaises
devraient rester à gauche ainsi les
projections donneraient une vingtaine de
sièges à la majorité socialiste une
dizaine pour la droite une équation tout
de même à deux inconnues que fera
d'abord le Front national encore en
liste sur 14 des 17 cantons dont celui
de Nevers 2 est celui surtout de
Fourchambault et puis enfin que feront
les quatre binômes encore en liste du
mouvement sans étiquette baptisan Nièvre
à venir vous le savez ce mouvement lancé
par le maire de Nevers bref ce soir la
Nièvre devrait faire partie des
départements de gauche qui résistent le
mieux à la pousser
UMP FN même si
une surprise ne sont pas à exclure merci
Régis à tout à l'heure Lilian molette la
tension est un peu tombée on peut le
dire dans la Nièvre oui chaque fois
qu'on parle de la Nièvre on parle de
symbole et bien il va peut-être falloir
chercher ailleurs pour le symbole
puisque les résultats du premier tour
n'ont pas annoncé la débâcle que le
contexte national aurait pu occasionné
après un effondrement aux européennes la
gauche dans son ensemble c'est ressaisi
avec 42% des voix dans ce premier tour
qui pourrait faire rêver bon nombre de
responsables socialistes et communiste
ailleurs en France et dans le même temps
la droite a payé son manque
d'implantation en profitant pas du
contexte de sanction du pouvoir les
candidats de droite n'ont recueilli que
22% des voix largement dépassées par le
Front National qui lui est devenu dans
ce département le véritable réceptacle
de la protestation avec 26% des voix la
situation est donc un peu moins
étouffante pour le président Patrice
Joly qu'il y a quelques semaines il nous
reste à nous rendre en Côte-d'Or à Dijon
où nous attend à liseré lise d'abord la
participation et que Dorian ont un peu
moins voté ce dimanche
oui effectivement Arnaud à 17h toute
participation pour la Côte d'Or
46,7% soit 0,8 points de moins par
rapport au premier tour à la même heure
donc des électeurs côtes d'Orient un peu
moins mobilisés le taux de participation
était déjà en baisse ce midi à 17%. ah
binôme élu au premier tour celui de
Châtillon-sur-Seine mené par Hubert
brigand il reste donc 22 cantons à
pourvoir et pas de gros bouleversements
dans l'Union de la Droite devrait
conserver l'avantage maison suivra avec
attention la résistance de la gauche sur
ces bastions de l'agglomération
dijonnaise une gauche arrivée en tête
dans cinq des six cantons dijonnais à
surveiller Dijon 3 qui comprend
notamment le quartier aux populaires des
Grésilles car le Front National s'est
invité dans la bataille qu'en sera-t-il
également pour la nouvelle guerre de
socialiste révélée lors des dernières
municipales Nathalie kanders sur Dijon 2
Céline maglika sur dijoncis ou encore
Océane sharigothard sur Dijon 4 en duel
très serré avec le tandem UMP
anarchiences Ludovic Rochette alors le
risque de perte pour la gauche se trouve
surtout dans certains quand on ruraux
qui lui était historiquement acquis la
situation s'annonce difficile notamment
à Montbard mais aussi pour les
triangulaires de longue vie
Nuits-Saint-Georges ou encore Arnel duc
marqué par une poussée de l'extrême
droite le Front National qui progresse
et espère placer des élus sur le canton
de braser en plaine par exemple mais
aussi à Chenôve et Saint-Apollinaire à
tout à l'heure vous êtes un homme pressé
vous voyez déjà plus loin oui nous a
parlé de ce deuxième tour qui vient de
se terminer à 19h sur l'agglomération
dijonnaise mais en fait ces résultats
vont nous faire basculer très vite sur
le troisième tour c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle l'élection du président et même
sur ce qu'on pourrait appeler
abusivement le quatrième tour les
élections régionales de décembre il faut
dire que le redécoupage a rééquilibré le
paysage du département ou le monde rural
était sur représenté ce rééquilibrage va
donc peut-être atténuer en partie la
tendance nationale et sera peut-être de
naturalité l'ampleur de la majorité
rappelons que François Sauvadet udaïque
il a besoin de l'UMP pour la solidité de
sa majorité et qu'il aura besoin de
l'UMP de Côte-d'Or pour les élections
régionales de décembre prochain dans
lesquels c'est déjà lancé l'UMP
prend-contois à la joie yandet dans la
coulisse le sénateur UMP de Côte-d'Or
Alain houper s'oppose à cette alliance
départementale le résultat de ce soir
établira la cote des uns et des autres
tout cela premier résultat à 20h15 tout
à l'heure Elsa grâce à un travail mené
en coulissant ce moment exactement comme
dimanche dernière nous pouvez suivre la
soirée électorale à la télévision 5
heures de direct on continue dispositif
exceptionnel pour vous permettre de
connaître les résultats en temps réel
partout en français surtout près de chez
vous en Bourgogne vous le voyez
documentaliste technicien journaliste
sont sur le pont vous pouvez découvrir
des 20h15 les premiers score dans les 85
cantons restant les scores les réactions
et les premières analyses des infos à
retrouver sur le net avec un site
complètement transformé pour l'occasion
et pour les plus mordu et bien nouveauté
vous pouvez déposer vos commentaires et
vos réactions sur les réseaux sociaux
hashtag FR3 Bourgogne F3 Bourgogne sur
Twitter France 3.fr France TV info
également.fr pour nous rejoindre nous
verrons vos messages s'afficher tout à
l'heure dans le courant de la soirée un
résultat tout de même disponible mais il
ne s'agit pas de politique mais de
cyclisme de sport pour vous signaler une
victoire tout à l'heure celle de
Jean-Christophe Perrot dans le Critérium
international pour la deuxième année
consécutive
licencier vous le savez en Bourgogne au
Creusot deuxième tour de France selon
dernier il s'est imposé tout à l'heure
en Corse devant le Franc-Comtois
Thibault fino autre star du dernier Tour
de France d'ailleurs France 3 et la
seule chaîne à vous proposer votre
édition spéciale élection départementale
ce soir encore la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs nous étions numéro 1 grâce à
vous à l'heure des premiers résultats
donc que soyez là tout à l'heure
également nous nous retrouvons à 20h15
après la Synthèse nationale que va vous
présenter Carole Gaessler et Francis
Letellier soirée spéciale France 3.fr et
on se retrouve donc à 20h15 pour les
tous premiers résultats dans votre
canton nous les détaillerons quand on
part canton tout de suite des idées de
sortie en Bourgogne et la météo on se
donne rendez-vous donc tout à l'heure à
partir de 20h15 pour vivre ensemble
cette soirée spéciale sur France 3
Bourgogne par les alentours de vous
rejoignez-nous n'oubliez pas Facebook et
Twitter pour tous vos messages vos
commentaires sur le net à tout à l'heure